[Musique]
la vie si tu kankan est astucieux
le plus sérieux il suffit de vouloir
revenir à un ami
[Musique]
surtout quand on joue enfin brice
comment vas tu es tu toi ça va bien bien
bien quoi et tu habillée comme ça l'a
tué tout bas oui oui oui parce que je
vais je vais au bal ce soir je vais au
bal des maisons à bages qui virait
peut-être non je ne pourrais pas ce
spectacle faut que je te fasse une
confession oui j'ai une grande surprise
pour toi est ce possible oui j'ai un
avis un des fils qui vient mon chéri
vient mon dieu qu'il est mignon et
dévoila c'est ton fils oui on mac qui te
ressemble un peu quand même hein oui oui
ce que tu voudrais être le parrain ob
volonté c'est un vrai plaisir
bonjour titou mais ça va après mois
fabrice a dit donc c'est pas tout ça
j'ai quand même j'ai quand même préparé
des tas de jeux à turin devant toi dans
la bassine vois tu je suis faut que je
fasse un choix s'il ya de l'eau il ya de
l'eau lowy à côté tu as des aiguilles
oui et alors je vais te demander c'est
de faire flotter l'éguille sur l'eau
comment tu veux que je fasse sauter une
aiguille sur l'eau oui ça paraît
impossible
c'est pas possible ça basset maison une
durable devra mettre une aiguille à ta
ça va couler forcément ça va couler une
aiguille sur l'eau voilà les banques
soutiennent
oui non ça marche pas by bull voilà
alors y'a un truc pour ça qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire alors tu prends une
feuille de papier à cigarette qui en a
là à combler mais ici oui attend feuille
de papier cigarette voit la pause tu la
pose délicatement sur l'eau à la surface
de l'eau bon délicatement délicatement
oui j'essaie et puis voilà maintenant
oui pose une aiguille sur le papier à
cigarette alors une aiguille sur le
papier à cigarette voilà voilà
ah bah oui forcément çà çà çà tient mais
c'est normal
non non c'est pas normal parce que le
papier fois autonome qui boudent thomas
le papier va descendre au fond de la
bassine vrai il peut l'aider ainsi tu
veux meilleures fins il vaut mieux
laisser tomber tout seul avant tu crois
et tu verras l'aiguillé
sur l'eau tu veux ça y est bleu c'est
comme ça quand même
tu es tellement maladroit oui et en
principe tu crois que l'aiguillé va
rester ah oui mais reste toujours
évident ça ça m'étonnerait quand même un
peu extraordinaire ça tue ça marche 1 ah
oui ça c'est fantastique c'est le sytème
dit je vais inventer
alors maintenant autre chose on a
beaucoup de choses à faire aujourd'hui
tu sais ce qu'on doit faire mais oui
devant la devanture va chercher un
panier de vente
à oui j'ai un panier l'abri à un panier
pour le voilà oui le prince oui tu vas
retrouver nos amis et on va jouer à un
jeu nouveau si le mot à mot alors enfin
avec ton panier là je vais là-bas tu vas
tu as par là bas j'y vais le montat
mottu maniaque
qu'est-ce que ça peut bien être que
cette affaire là le mot tamo exactement
alors dans ton panier il ya des tas de
petits cartons qui représentent des
objets divers là des animaux des plantes
en fait des tas de choses que tu connais
très bien et tous ces objets ont une
particularité ils sont tous désignés par
des mots d'une syllabe par exemple tu
vois un chat un saut une si tu vas
commencer par tirer cinq cartes au
hasard
bon alors 1,5 2 3 4 et 5
oui très bien alors va les placer sur le
tableau là pour que tout le monde les
voit bien morte où va le tableau il donc
tu peux bouger il faut que je bouge
beaucoup dans ce jeu là un là là alors
nous tous label belles pousses moussu
rapidos épique en boule et puis vous
tout cela qui nous regarde et nous
allons essayer de faire des mots de deux
ou trois syllabes ou même plus c'est
alors qu'au prix fabrice oui mais si tu
le veux bien pour résumer on va d'abord
dire ce que c'est à chaque fois ça c'est
un cerf je me trompe par un essai alors
ça ça c'est apparemment un lit là je
suppose que c'est un amant un mât de
bateau à la une fait à la une vi voilà
alors alors tu vois que je t'explique
encore par exemple s'il y avait un
dessin qui représente un chat et un
autre une si tu pourrais faire châssis
ah oui achats d'automobiles voilà voilà
alors ben si personne n'arrive à rien
avant ne rien faire avec les avec les
mots des cinq premiers cartons on en
tire un sixième septième et puis à la
fin du jeu on fait le compte à ce
monsieur
moi ça me ferait bien parce que on n'est
pas obligés de connaître l'orthographe
ou au fait attention méfie toi tu
pourras avoir de désagréables surprises
bon oui mais tu ne vois rien de rien à
faire pour l'instant
bah non non moi je ne vois rien ma mais
rien ou peu dont moi je vois quelque
chose
ah je vois serre et vis ça fait service
qu'est ce que tu me racontes insert
attend hummer ou zen oui puis la vis
ah oui ça fait sept vis
bravo très astucieux ça on va l'écrire
services et bien joué je l'avais pas
revu
il est très bon cela sert service bien
joué eh ben tu as bien compris un fatras
oui oui non là il a été très bon il l'a
bien vu continuer cet ami on continue on
continue ou tu te dire un autre carton
au bas si tu veux où je vais tirer un
autre carton alors bien sûr on peut
servir des trois cartons qui n'ont pas
été utilisées a bien entendu ça c'est
table c'est un saut ça suffit tu crois
pour faire autre chose allait tirer un
autre aller oui parce que je crois que
l'on n'a pas ce qu'il faut pour faire un
autre mot qu'est ce que tu as trouvé là
bas apparemment il s'agit de la de la
terre de notre planète la terre c'est
difficile
oui à et je crois que j'ai une idée
écoute bien oui quand on est tout seul
oui alors vraiment vraiment vraiment
tout seul j'ai trouvé j'ai trouvé tu as
trouvé tout encore oui quoi tôt le so we
le saut le lit oui et puis la terre nous
sommes d'accord lippert faso
ici le lit là et la terre bravo c'est ce
que je voulais que tu trouves tu aurais
pu le trouver ça pousse mousse u11
solitaire alors saut lee terre avec un
nid à nay et 1 voix solitaire
voilà ça m'a bien jouer et pas mal pour
un début
bien joué tu as très très bien joué tout
cas encore bien écoute puisque tu as été
le vainqueur je te propose de
prendre au hasard une lettre qui a été
envoyée par un certain nombre de nos
petits amis et tu va me prendre une
désignera est tombé qu'une enveloppe et
puis on va bien voir et bien râler car
celle là tu veux cela tient bon à l'art
est un jeu de shoot la prends je te la
prend et puis nous allons voir ce qu'il
ya dans cette lettre c'est pas pour moi
non plus pour nous a pour nous watt
s'est adressé à nous tous
alors il s'agit de c'est la maman de la
petite vermandel qui nous écrit
charmante petite vermandel elle voudrait
ah bah tiens elle voudrait le disque
les quatre amis tu sais la tat etc
eh bien je crois que nous ferons un
plaisir de le lui envoyer ce disque très
bientôt car elle nous nous signale
qu'elle ne l'a pas trouvée là l'affairé
fait c'est entendu nous allons vous
l'envoyez très bientôt madame vermandel
et vous pourrez les payas petite fille
la petite fille s'appelle magali mignon
l'axé charmant st
bravo tout concours grâce à toi la
petite magali recevra la chanson des 80
m bravo bravo black eyed peas maggie est
battu à l on le fait on lui fait une
bise glacée fond fait une bise à magali
évident fabrice oui maintenant c'est à
nous will smith est un petit jeu wii est
d'habitude on y va ah oui on a été
attaqué après ton marqueur en bas juste
qu'il faut bon je sors chien j'ai un mot
terrible attaque aurait deviné
oui c'est un mot en anglettre hand il
est audible être oui on commence par
quoi
eh ben la première c1 pa11 paix à la
paix comme d'habitude à huit petits
fruits petits traits pour la lettre du
mans 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et la dernière un n
1 n a alors je je dois te prévenir tout
de suite mais il ya beaucoup de
changements ah oui oui peinture
d'aujourd'hui j'ai décidé de tout
changer
ah bon alors les les animaux les plantes
c'est terminé que se termine ce prix je
te fait deviner à un mot c'est très
spécial c'est quoi des transports ou des
transports oui tous les âges tous les
moyens de transport alors j'y vais sur
la vente est ce que c'est un transport
qu'on rencontre sur les routes où il est
très particulier sur les routes en eau
pas aux autres
non parce que c'est un transport qui
dix des rails non plus y'a pas de ride
dans les airs ah non non plus non non ça
serait ce que c'est un transport qui se
déplace sur l'eau sur l'eau sur la mer
d'oman sur la main sur la mer oui oui un
bateau alors j'ai très spécial oui c'est
un bateau un bâton spéciale
oui très spéciale 1 il commence par un
pays qui se termine par analogie voit
pas bien évident tu ne vas pas non plus
je te donne la troisième lettre s'il te
plaît la troisième lettre ses 1ers et ce
pendant toute guerre quand même si c'est
un bateau de guerre c'est pour ça qu'il
est très spécial je me dis pas que c'est
par un porte avions un porte avion tu as
trouvé alors commenté qui porte avions
porte avions comme chaque prénom choisi
part1 alors attends prt là nous sommes
d'accord et oui faut un trait d'union ma
petite radio ouï pierre caillot et puis
avions pays au n abordent que l'avion
sur un porte-avion il ya qu un seul
avion à habas non non non il y en a
plusieurs
et alors comment tu te débrouilles avec
sa vache et un porte avion c'est ça
alors porte avions on ne met pas des ce
ah bon il faut un essaim d'abeilles
route sur un porte-avion il ya beaucoup
d'avions il ya beau mettre un ace ah oui
alors voilà gens là là tu es toujours
aussi nul cette finale
alors là il faut mettre un trading
intraction porte-avions avec un avion
avec un parce que ya plusieurs mois
fabrice oui est ce que tu sais combien
d'hommes bien sûr un porte avions parce
que y'a peut-être les avions les gars
des hommes
oui on bosse à un porte-avions peut-il
un porte-avions moyen de me nommer un
gros porte-avions 4000 sommes à peu près
en bas bravo alors là tu es très très
fort a berné c'est qu'elle est bien la
marine tu savais qu'en pourri ça pouvait
contenir jusqu'à 4000 hommes véritable
petite ville
[Musique]
avec moi bonjour bunble est ce que tu es
prêt pour jouer à notre petit jeu
musical ont été en rappel le principe
est métissée il te suffit de compléter
les mots que je vais laissé inachevé
dans la petite histoire que je vais te
raconter tulle et complète ses mots par
des notes de musique que tu places sur
cette portée à la fin toutes ces notes
de noront l'air de la chanson quand je
vais justement te raconter l'histoire
je suis prof c'est une chanson très
bonne yonne au minium c'est ça une
chanson que tous les enfants apprennent
lorsqu'ils vont bord de la mer surtout
lorsqu'ils vivent pour la première fois
car qu'est ce qu'il découvre la première
fois qu'il sent sur une plage de l'eau
beaucoup d'eau et au bout il y eu au
beau milieu des villes amies en bas et
les musées bien urbain bon alors je te
disais donc qu'il découvre au beau
milieu de toute cette eau des bateaux
issa salifou petit peu infléchies
réfléchir très faibles alors tu l'as mis
en eau à lyon bon c'est pareil alors il
se demande comment ces bateaux peuvent
bien se déplacer sur cette grande
étendue de dodo boulot et ils ont
l'habitude du c'est de voir des voitures
des bicyclettes qui roule sur des routes
mais pour ces bateaux il doit bien y
avoir ce thème mais laisse comme un
suspect est patent alors quel système
est ce que ce sont des grandes roues des
grandes jambes il faut bien qu'il y ait
une installation une installation à
l'arrêt et la publie maintenant les
notes que tu as place et mimi raid aussi
là c'est qui ces champions à tanger
oui je crois que je sais ce que c'est
[Musique]
mais oui en gros bêta s'il ne l'avait
pas il affirmé non profitons pas
puisqu'il se laisse le petit bébé qui a
chanté avec new fabris toi aussi à
travers les quatre déjà papa famille des
matelas anti feu après que la vie majeur
s'est désisté et rzeszow fait des choses
mais comme je n'ai pas de mine war negro
à faire attention les quatre amis sont
descendus 10 et 4 ça me sens heureux car
il aime la vie
m
et tous
mais j'arrive à jouer aujourd'hui
[Musique]
vouloir devenir familier
e
[Musique]